كل شيء يحصل على الارض الاوكرانيه يشير
الى ان القتال الدمار الحرب كل شيء مستمر
لا نيه لدى بوتن للتراجع ولا لدى
الاوكرانيين
نيه للاستسلام لاحلام القيصر مقال مشترك
كتبته وزيره الخارجيه الامريكيه السابقه
كوندوليزا رايس ووزير الدفاع السابق روبرت
غيتس في صحيفه واشنطن بوست تحدث فيها عن
نيه بوتن سيطره على كاملي اوكرانيا وان لم
يحقق ذلك في يريد تدميرها كدوله قابله
للحياه يرى المسؤولان الامريكيان رفيعان
السابقان ان بوتن يعتقدوا ان مهمته
الاساسيه هي اعاده تاسيس الامبراطوريه
الروسيه مثل ما لحظه
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي السابق منذ سنوات
فانه لا يمكن ان تكون هناك امبراطوريه
روسيه من دون اوكرانيا اول سيده القمل على
ارهاق الاوكرانيين وتلاشي وحده الغرب
بمواجهه حرب على جارته الغربيه لكن الوضع
عليه هو ان الاقتصاد الروسي والشعب
سيعانيان كثيرا مع استمرار الحرب
رئيس وجيتسا يرياني ان الهزيمه ليست خيارا
بالنسبه لبوتن ولا يمكنه ان يتنازل
لاوكرانيا عن المقاطعات الشرقيه الاربع
التي اعلن انها جزء من روسيا وانه اعتمد
خلال سنوات على الصبر لتحقيق اهدافه
لكنهما حذرات من انه على رغم الرد
الاوكراني البطولي الا ان اقتصاد البلاد
في حاله من الفوضى وقد فر الملايين من
السكان ودمرت البنيه التحتيه اضافه الى ان
كثيرا من الثروه المعدنيه والقدره
الصناعيه الكبيره والاراضي الزراعيه باتت
تحت السيطره الروسيه
وفي غياب اختراق اوكراني كبير ضد القوات
الروسيه ستزداد الضغوط الضغوط الغربيه على
كياف للتفاوض على وقف لاطلاق النار مع
مرور اشهر من الجمود العسكري وفي ظل ظروف
الحاليه فان اي اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار من
شانه ان يترك القوات الروسيه في وضع القوي
الاستئناف حربها عندما تكون جاهزه
تقول رايس ووزير الدفاع السابق في مقالهما
ان خطاب الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي امام
الكونجرس الشهر الماضي ذكره الماضي رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني الاسبق واستنتشر في
فبراير من عام 41 حين قال اعطونا الادوات
وسننهي المهمه وابدا كل من رايس وجيتس
توافقا مع تصميم اداره على تجنب المواجهه
المباشره مع روسيا لكنهما قال انه مع ذلك
قد لا يمنح بوتن هذا الخيار للولايات
المتحده وان طريقه تجنب المواجهه مع روسيا
في المستقبل هي مساعده اوكرانيا على سد
الغزو الان تنهي رايس ما قالها المشترك مع
جيد بالقول هذا هو درس التاريخ الذي ينبغي
ان يوجهنا وهو يطفي حازم ملحه على
الاجراءات التي يجب اتخاذها قبل فوات
الاوان يقول مدون عسكري روسي شهير انهم لا
يؤمنون بوجود دوله اسمها اوكرانيا وان
المفاوضات والهدن امر غبي بمناسبه دينيه
في اشاره الى الهدنه التي تمت في عيد
الميلاد الارثوذكسي وانه يجب انهاء المهمه